>> HARDWICK: IT'S TIME FOR OUR
NEXT GAME, LOCO-MERCIALS:
SPORTZ EDITION.
>> OOH.
>> HARDWICK: HEY, KIDS, TAKE IT
FROM ME, @MIDNIGHT MVP CHRIS
HARDWICK-- THE WORLD'S WORST
ACTING COMES FROM SOME OF THE
WORLD'S BEST ATHLETES.
I'M... N... I'LL S... YOUR...
I'LL SHOW YOU, THE LOCAL VIEWER,
COMMERCIALS FEATURING SPORTS
STARTS AND YOU HAVE TO GUESS
WHICH PRODUCT THEY'RE MAKING FOR
THEIR PITCH.
FIRST ONE.
THIS AD STARRING CHICAGO BULLS
ACTING GREAT SCOTTIE PIPPEN.
IS IT FOR MR. NICK'S NICK-O-TIME
BAIL BONDS OR MR...
(BELL DINGS)
>> YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: MR. SUBMARINE'S
SIX-FOOT PARTY SUBS, JASON.
>> UH, IT IS MR. SUBMARINE'S
SIX-FOOT PARTY SUBS.
I'VE ACTUALLY SEEN THIS
COMMERCIAL BEFORE.
>> HARDWICK: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> IT'S THE ROSETTA STONE OF BAD
SPORTS ACTING.
>> ♪ CHICAGO'S ORIGINAL
SUBMARINE, MR. SUBMARINE. ♪
>> THIS IS ONE SIX-FOOTER I
CAN'T HANDLE ONE-ON-ONE.
LADIES, LET'S HAVE A PARTY.
>> ...SUB OR REGULAR SUB PILED
HIGH WITH YOUR FAVORITE MEATS
AND CHEESES.
>> FOR THE BEST-TASTING MEAL
AROUND, MR. SUBMARINE IS THE
REAL STUFF.
>> HE DUNKS THE SUB.
>> HARDWICK: YOU KNOW... SEE...
THAT WAS REALLY BAD.
>> THAT WAS CRAZY.
>> HARDWICK: AND THAT WAS THE
BEST TAKE?
>> THAT WAS IT.
>> YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: NEXT ONE.
PITTSBURGH PENGUINS STAR MARIO
LEMIEUX AND THIS TERRIFIED BOY.
ARE THEY PROMOTING MARIO
LEMIEUX'S LIFE-SIZED POSTER
NIGHT OR MARIO LEMIEUX'S
"CROSS-CHECK YOUR HOMEWORK"
CAMPAIGN?
(BELL DINGS)
YES, MATT.
>> I GOT TO SAY POSTER,
LIFE-SIZED POSTER NIGHT.
>> HARDWICK: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> IT'S MARIO LEMIEUX LIFE-SIZED
POSTER NIGHT COMPLIMENTS OF
THRIFT DRUG.
>> OH, NO, NO, DON'T, OH, GOD.
>> ALL FANS 16 AND UNDER RECEIVE
A LIFE-SIZED POSTER GROWTH CHART
FEATURING MARIO LEMIEUX.
>> OH, WHAT IS HAPPENING?
>> SATURDAY NIGHT, THE PENGUINS
HOST MONTREAL.
>> OH, MY GOD, THAT'S, LIKE, A
THREAT... IT LOOKS LIKE A
THREAT, LIKE HE'S SHAKING HIM
DOWN.
>> HARDWICK: NOT ONLY
THREATENING, BUT HOW INVASIVE OF
THAT KID'S PERSONAL SPACE?
>> OH, NO, NO, NO, NO.
I-I HAVE A SON AND I DON'T LOOK
INTO HIS EYES THAT MUCH.
>> YEAH.
>> MY... I JUST GOT AN AMBER
ALERT ON MY PHONE, AND THAT
HAPPENED YEARS AGO.
>> FROM THE PAST?
>> HARDWICK: I FEEL LIKE...
I FEEL...
THAT KID IS, UH, HOPEFULLY JUST
GOTTEN OUT OF THERAPY.
>> YEAH.